I love learning I've never actually
thought I was you know starting a
company as such I just saw situations as
I traveled in life where I felt I could
improve on the way things were being
done by other people so and you know so
I would you know one way favorite
phrases is screw it let's do it I've
used that phrase a lot of times and we
and and we've you know we just love
going in and trying to shake up
industries and doing it better than it's
been done before yeah when we launched
Virgin Atlantic 30 years ago the New
York Times did a review and they did
some market research and they said you
know first of all with a name like
virgin it's not going to go the whole
way but but but sec but secondly that
and they did market research which said
only 7% of people would fly on an
airline called virgin and and we put our
hands up and said 7% would be just fine
so so we carried on with it but there
are a lot of there were a lot of
skeptics out there and there always will
be lots of skeptics when when you want
to start something new everybody will
tell you why it's a bad idea why you
shouldn't do it why you'll you know lose
everything you've got and in the end you
just gotta get out and try to prove them
wrong you just watched two amazing clips
with Sir Richard Branson take the next
three minutes and sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]